heute in goslar begrüße ich jetzt
herzlich den vorsitzenden der
atlantik-brücke sigmar gabriel die
atlantik-brücke vielleicht das kurzem
verständnis ein netzwerk von deutschen
und us-amerikanischen einflussreichen
personen aus politik und wirtschaft
schauen wir einmal auf das g7
außenministertreffen herr gabriel wenn
wir uns die agenda anschauen verhältnis
zu russland stichwort nord stream
verhältnis zu china stichwort
unterdrückung der uiguren dann hat sich
doch in der zeit wo sie aus minister
waren und auch vizekanzler
doch überhaupt nicht viel verändert das
wohl war die konflikte sind in der welt
eher größer geworden aber das problem
war ja dass die g7 de facto nicht mehr
existiert haben
ich erinnere mich noch an das erste
treffen dass es gab also donald trump
präsident war der wollte erst gar nicht
hin und als er da war hatte am ende per
twitter aus dem abfliegenden flugzeug
die ergebnisse des treffens sozusagen
zunichte gemacht also das schon gut dass
es überhaupt wieder den versuch gibt
zusammenzuarbeiten das war durch trump
völlig zerstört aber ist es nur der ton
der sich geändert hat oder hat sich auch
inhaltlich fast geändert weil die
forderung der usa stopp von nord stream
oder auch beispielsweise härtere gangart
gegen china das ja gleich geblieben auch
unter beiden das ist auch nicht neu es
gab solche kritiken ja auch schon vor
ort rammt die frage es wie gehe ich
damit um ich glaube dass die
ursprüngliche idee die trump hatte man
könne china sozusagen entkoppeln vom
rest der welt dass das nicht
funktionieren wird und dass das beiden
und auch tony blinken wissen ein 1,4
milliarden volk kann man nicht unter
hausarrest stellen aber was man kann ist
gemeinschaft mit anderen
industriestaaten demokratischen
industriestaaten sich strategien
überlegen wie man die chinesen sozusagen
auch ausbalanciert wie man in den
wettbewerb mit ihnen geht warum gibt es
keine amerikanisch europäische
initiative die zentral asien oder afrika
auch infrastrukturinvestitionen anbietet
die mit dieser seitenstraßen initiative
der chinese in einen wettbewerb geht
warum lassen wir zu dass selbst eine
die bahnverbindung von budapest und
belgrad durch china gebaut wird und
nicht durch die europäische union ist ja
keineswegs so dass wir hilflos sind und
die zusammenarbeit dieser
industriestaaten das schon der richtige
weg aber es muss halt auch mehr werden
als darüber zu reden
schauen wir mal auf uns europäer
vielleicht auch ein bisschen
selbstkritisch sind wir dann nicht zu
sehr von unseren wirtschaftsinteressen
geleitet ich meine sie kommen aus dem vw
land niedersachsen und auch volkswagen
ist ja sehr aktiv in china und das thema
menschenrechte wird immer nur sehr
vorsichtig sowohl von wirtschaftler die
aber auch von politikern angegangen
müsste man da nicht auch sagen okay die
wirtschaft muss dann auch mal
zurückstehen
also wenn ich mich in meine zeit
erinnere dann kann ich sagen dass
deutschland jedenfalls zu den ländern
gehört hat die öffentliche in china
menschenrechte thematisiert haben andere
reden gerne zu hause darüber
und wenn sie vor ort sind schweigen sie
manchmal oder gar nicht so selten
diese konnten dieser konflikt den sie
beschreiben der wird bleiben die usa
kaufen in russland öl weil sie es nicht
mehr in venezuela oder iran kaufen
wollen wir sind eine exportorientierte
region nicht nur deutschland sondern
ganz europa wenn wir erklären war werden
wir werden sozusagen unsere
wertvorstellungen menschenrechte zum
alleinigen maßstab unseres
wirtschaftlichen handelns machen dann
müssen wir bereit sein
massive folgen und erhebt erhebliche
arbeitslosigkeit in kauf zu nehmen
das werden wir alle nicht machen und
deswegen wird es dieses spannungsfeld
zwischen wirtschaftlichen interessen und
menschenrechten und westlichen werten
immer geben
jedenfalls solange diese länder sich
nicht ändern die hoffnung ist dass man
zwei dinge erreichen kann erstens dass
sie wenigstens im handel sich fair
verhalten länder wie china
beispielsweise und dass wir verhindern
dass aus solchen konflikten wie wir sie
haben echte kriege werden denn auch
solche gefahren gibt es heute auf der
welt und dann ist schon viel erreicht zu
glauben dass wir sozusagen durch druck
bei uns im inneren chinas viel erreichen
werden die hoffnung habe ich nicht
länder verändern sich aus sich selbst
heraus aber nicht dadurch dass andere
wirtschaftlichen druck machen
sie haben eben ein anderes land
angesprochen russland das war am rande
des g7 gipfels ja auch noch ein thema
zwischen dem bundesaußenminister
das und aus seinem us-amtskollegen die
frage nord stream die zwei der weiterbau
der gaspipeline
da gibt es ja auch innerhalb der spd
durchaus unterschiedliche ansichten
müsste man auch nicht dort einfach viel
mehr die wirtschaftlichen interessen
zurückstellen und sagen okay das muss
man auch in einem globalen zusammenhang
sehen also dass müssen sich nicht mehr
sagen das müssen sie dann der
öffentlichkeit sagen dass deutschland
wirtschaftliche schäden hinnehmen soll
übrigens nicht nur deutschland sondern
auch andere damit diese pipeline nicht
bauen in wahrheit geht es darum was ganz
anderes
denn vor 25 jahren den energiemarkt in
europa liberalisiert und dann gesagt wir
schaffen europäische regeln
und wer sich an diese regeln hält der
kann selbst entscheiden woher seine
energieressourcen bekommt das ist das
sozusagen die aufgabe dann der
unternehmen
und wer sich an die regeln hält der darf
das und jetzt ist doch die frage ist das
richtig dass sich eine befreundetes land
für die usa
in diesen europäischen energiemarkt ein
möchten ist das sozusagen der umgang den
wir haben wollen
wenn man trotzdem falsch findet dann
muss das eine europäische entscheidung
sein
aber dann muss man den menschen auch
sagen dass das konsequenzen hat und zwar
auch wirtschaftliche in deutschland in
unseren nachbarländern
ich halte es nur für ein problem
sozusagen aus dem ausland heraus eine
energieleistung seiner energie
richtlinien hier zu verändern
sozusagen die liberalisierung des
energiemarktes vor 25 jahren rückgängig
zu machen und wieder zu politischen
entscheidungen mitten rein in den
energiemarkt zu treffen das halte ich
für ein problem und das würden die usa
sich übrigens umgekehrt auch nicht
erlauben und noch mal ungefähr in dem
gleichen finanzvolumen wie europa gas
midstream zwei aus russland kauft will
wollen die vereinigten staaten öl aus
russland kaufen
insofern man muss ein bisschen aufpassen
dass man nicht anders sagen
unterschiedliche maßstäbe anlegt
übrigens es ist nicht die erste pipeline
die unter sanktionsdruck gerät die erste
war glaube ich noch 162 die zweite in
den 70er jahren immer sind die
sanktionen am ende aufgehoben worden
weil die vereinigten staaten gesagt
haben wegen eines konfliktes wollen wir
nicht die guten beziehungen die wir
ansonsten in deutschland
und europa haben gefährden ich glaube
man wird auch in diesem fall kompromisse
finden kurze frage zum schluss herr
gabriel vorsitzender der atlantik-brücke
was erwarten wir von den
europäisch-amerikanischen beziehungen in
den nächsten jahren vor allen dingen
auch unter dem unter dem neuen sozusagen
umstand dass großbritannien nicht mehr
mitglied der eu ist haben wir da ein
neues kräfteverhältnis mehr sicher haben
wir ein neues kräfteverhältnis die
europäische union gilt weltweit als
schwächer weil die briten gegangen sind
wir haben in amerika in präsidenten dem
es lieber gewesen wäre dass
großbritannien noch mitglied der eu es
weil auch die vereinigten staaten wissen
dass in der welt des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts man alliierte und partner
braucht und da wäre sozusagen eine
starke europäische union als partner den
amerikanern lieber als eine geschwächte
aber es ist so dass zum beispiel china
den austritt großbritanniens aus der
europäischen union als signal der
schwäche wahrnimmt wir als europäer wir
werden als reich aber als schwach
angesehen und das müssen wir verändern
wir müssen technologisch besser werden
wenn wir müssen wirtschaftlich stärker
werden und wir werden auch das wären die
amerikaner von uns verlangen
ein teil der sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik in unserer
unmittelbaren nachbarschaft zum beispiel
in richtung nordafrika selbst übernehmen
müssen
dafür werden die vereinigten staaten uns
nicht mehr zur verfügung stehen
das war sigmar gabriel vorsitzender der
atlantik-brücke herr gabriel herzlichen
dank nach goslar für dieses gespräch